last week
virtually every media outlet from around
the world reported on the newly
discovered void inside the Great Pyramid
of Giza a massive chamber discovered
through particle physics and mu on
technology approximately 100 feet or 30
meters in length and about 26 feet high
but in this video I'm going to discuss
something a bit different which is the
completely unusual reaction from the two
most leading authorities on Egyptology
and archeology
take for example mark Lehner and Zahi
Hawass well let's start with mark Lehner
who said two things that completely
contradicted the press briefing on
behalf of scan pyramids he stated that
one this void is an incline so it's
likely to not have any type of burial or
any type of artifacts inside of it and
he also theorized that it was likely to
be a structural support necessary to
keep weight off the Grand Gallery but
wait a second this completely
contradicts what the president and
co-founder of heritage innovation
Preservation Institute which of course
oversees the scan pyramids project
his name is Mehdi TOB and he
specifically states that they have no
idea if this void is horizontal or
inclined and also the engineers
overseeing this project have completely
ruled out the possibility that this void
has any type of purpose involving the
structural integrity of the pyramid
itself so here you have mark Lehner
doing interviews with the BBC The New
York Times and other media outlets from
around the world but did he even read or
watch the press briefing did he even
look at any of the information he
immediately starts doing interviews and
contradicts the actual facts that were
presented in this find I mean where is
his due diligence mark Lehner is the
director of ancient Egypt Research
Association and his works are cited in
virtually every textbook and the subject
of the pyramids and the Sphinx around
the world and then you have Zahi Hawass
the former minister of Antiquities for
Egypt who is of course fired for a
variety of reasons and then just a few
years later was implicated in a massive
theft of ancient relics from pyramids
and got off the hook because of his
connections and inside corruption this
is the same guy who has come
lately refused to acknowledge or even
discuss the water erosion around the
enclosure of the Sphinx
he's also refused to discuss the site of
Gobekli Tepe and he has some really
unusual reactions to this newly
discovered void in the Great Pyramid
quote this paper offers nothing to
Egyptology zero he even referred to the
individuals involved as propagandists
and saying that they were wrong to call
their findings a new discovery and this
is where things get a bit more
interesting because he goes on the state
that Egyptologist and archaeologists
have known for years about the existence
of several spaces inside the Great
Pyramid and mark Lehner said something
similar where he told the New York Times
that the Great Pyramid is like Swiss
cheese rather than cheddar and saying
that this void is most likely no big
deal wait a second so a void that has
remarkable similarities to that of the
Grand Gallery is no big deal but what's
with this analogy of Swiss cheese and
these many other voids that they've
known about I mean can you show me some
publications that mention all these
voids I only know of one other one which
was discovered two years ago through
scanned pyramids and you can see it here
mentioned in the same discovery as this
massive void same company same
organization and two years ago down to
almost the day they still haven't
drilled into and by they the Egyptian
authorities I mean how long does it take
to drill a hole to make the decision to
do so and they just sitting on this
they've known that there's been a void
in the Great Pyramid for more than two
years and they've done nothing about it
don't you find that interesting the
reason why you should find that
interesting is because there's already
examples of a cover-up where the
Egyptian authorities including Zahi
Hawass have done research inside the
Great Pyramid of Giza without the
public's knowledge and lied about it
take for example the 1993 versus the
2002 research of this small tunnel shaft
inside the Great Pyramid where after the
Egyptian authorities since Iowa had said
that no one had been in there ever since
when they revisited the site nine years
later the two handles were broken and
missing and clearly there's some had
gone in there this is be honest they did
their own research and they found some
reason to lie about it
what's that about but let me keep going
because the evidence actually gets more
disturbing why would mark Lehner and
Zahi Hawass be so dismiss
of this new find well you may not be
aware but four days prior to the
November 2nd press release of the newly
discovered void mark Lehner Zahi Hawass
released their new book that the
co-wrote together titled the definitive
history Giza and the pyramids and that
was released on October 29th and when
you consider the obvious fact that mark
Lehner had no idea of the information
that was presented at press release
prior he was obviously left out of the
loop and sigmaz aji o oz who condemned
these people as propagandists and said
that he should be more involved maybe
just maybe their book doesn't contain
any of the information about all these
voids this cheddar this Swiss cheese
analogy I haven't read the book but can
anyone answer and leave a comment
whether they mention anything about
these multiple voids or if they just
mentioned that one which of course was
covered from two years ago what about
the rest because this seems to be new to
me I mean did I miss the memo was this
mentioned in some text book about all
these other voids
I mean it doesn't seem like the public
or there's any information or can
someone provide a publication from
anything written from Zahi Hawass or
mark Lehner including this book or
anywhere else hmm
now if you think I'm reaching on the
suppression and cover-up of information
and knowledge from the masses on behalf
of these mainstream Egyptologists and
archaeologists well take just one
example of that of the Great Sphinx and
I made a video on this the link will the
end of the video of course but mark
Lehner was the first to excavate the
tunnels underneath the Sphinx and this
was in the 70s and then he and Zahi
Hawass had denied the existence of these
tunnels for decades until Zahi Hawass
eventually admitted it and said well
these don't go anywhere there's nothing
down there and as you can see here they
never even show you one picture not one
video exists at all of these hidden
chambers and tunnels that do indeed
exist under the Sphinx I mean to change
your stories and deny it and not to have
one picture a video in existence of
these tunnels guys connect the dots on
this but it gets even worse mark Lehner
even though he himself and you can see
in videos and I have a video on this too
the link will be at the end where every
single example of how the ancient
Egyptians or at least the theories of
how they cut and carved stone has been
ultimately debunked and this all ties
back into the theories of the Great
Pyramid of Giza was built prior to
the Cataclysm of 12,000 years ago but
the information is there that strongly
suggests that the Great Pyramid of Giza
was something far more advanced
sophisticated and technologically based
and the authorities that oversee these
sites know about it and it's time that
we start asking new questions and that
they hurry up the stupid process and
drill the damn holes into these chambers
to see what is in there drill a three
millimeter or one-inch hole they've
already discussed doing it because where
it stands right now they say they want
to spend the next couple years having
archaeologists and Egyptologist from
around the world consider and debate and
discuss what this void might be shut up
drill the freaking hole stick a camera
in there and find out but when you look
it would happen between 1993 and 2002
well something just tells me that the
authorities that do run the show want to
see first so it makes you wonder what's
really going on there but I'll close up
there I'm Jimmy this is bright insight
well I can subscribe leave me a comment
and as you can see I've got a new place
I got a new moved in this is a new
studio I'll make a video about that so
this will all be changing as I make
upgrades as we go but anyways I'll close
up there check out the videos that are
linked here and take care everybody